[Music]
morning Biddy
morning sword cut this is my eighth
feature film having designed for Paul
Thomas Anderson the film is a dream for
me to be able to create all these
garments from scratch the initial
research was following what Paul had
been reading what Paul had been looking
at and then really looking at the script
myself and seeing how we could use what
had inspired Paul and turn it into
storytelling with clothes my brother is
adored by the women who wear our design
it's very interesting to think about
designing in the hand of someone else
how flirty does it get how stodgy is it
how risque for a long time we avoided
things like strapless dresses which were
huge in the 50s but at some meeting or
at some point I'd heard from Daniel the
Reynolds would have thought that that
was vulgar so you're constantly
assessing you know is this something
that would be within Reynolds tastes you
look beautiful
as far as choosing the colors for the
house of Woodcock we sat one day with
Paul and thought about what exactly is
the house of Woodcock and I think deep
rich colors a lot of lace used
juxtaposing textures so as that
signature was developed then the choices
kind of followed within those parameters
come on I think perhaps the black lace
dress that Alma wears really stands out
I really loved it so much I'm most proud
of the fact that they all kind of work
in the scenes themselves and tell the
story and I think that's the subtle
thing that always is like a challenge
and making sure that it doesn't over
share
the scene but works within that
[Music]